a very slight sabbatical but nothing
else apart from that ultimately science
will provide the answer but right now
it's still trying to catch up with this
Novell virus here at this private cancer
clinic staff are being screened to see
if they've produced antibodies to covert
19 a small localized initiative but one
that could have far-reaching and
significant consequences
professor sakura is using sugan tech
kits from south korea
they're also widely used in germany to
countries with effective proven testing
regimes how reliable they are is what we
want to know so we're doing an exercise
today where we're taking blood from
everybody and comparing this kit with
formal blood samples done in a much more
precise and obviously more expensive
assay in the laboratory you can see a
line appearing 15 minutes later and we
have the results so this test is telling
me I haven't built up an immune response
to covert 19 which probably means I've
never been infected
the 10-pound kits need further
validating so the samples are dispatched
to a laboratory in London here they're
screened again using industry standard
immunology analyzers governments across
the world are racing to find a proven
antibody test it would map the true
spread of the virus and essentially
allow people with a virus immunity to
return to society but it's proving
difficult everything in medicine takes
time it's not something that you can do
just by waving a wand so it needs proper
verification in these trials
professor Sakura is looking for
consistency for the self testing kits to
match the expensive lab based tests
there's a breakthrough we have a
positive result here as well this is the
second one we've that's fantastic two
staff members have tested positive not
only are they positive in this complex
laboratory based assay which is very
precise they're also positive on the
china kits and on the Korean kits
they're immune and hopefully they're
completely healthy and can work normally
from now on
professor Sakura is sharing his results
with the government there are of course
still many unanswered questions but it
is a small hopeful step forward one that
might show us away out of this pandemic
Ashish Joshi sky news